- What the fuck is the difference between
peeing in the shower and
using your shower as a toilet?
The shower is a toilet at that point.
- You're taking a shower
while you're peeing!
- That doesn't make it better!
- Killing--
- Peeing in the shower. Come
on. Admit it. You've done it.
Have you? Filthy. Or is it?
Look, I don't know. It's not my call.
But I think we owe it to
ourselves to talk about it.
So with that in mind,
we've brought people here
from both sides of the
issue to argue their cases.
Peeing in the shower. It's debatable.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Chris and I'm for
peeing in the shower.
- I'm against peeing in the shower.
- I pee in the shower.
- I for obvious reasons,
do not pee in the shower.
- You shouldn't pee in your
bath tub or your shower.
- It's all pipes.
(dramatic music)
- You're literally in the
cleanest place you can be...
- You've got soap if
you're really that afraid
of your own pee.
- I can see what your
finger's pointing to.
- Oh yeah. You.
- It's an argument of somebody who
isn't comfortable with themselves.
I think you're afraid
of being a human being.
- No, I think you're trying not to be.
- Drought. Save water.
- There are kids all over
the world that would be
happy to take a shower
in your urine puddle.
- In your pee? You just
said you think children
desire your piss to roll around in.
Are you listening to yourself?
- You really want to save the environment?
You Greenpeace hippy?
- You think that three
gallons, one to three gallons
you're saving on that flush is making
the difference that California needs?
- Every little bit helps Keith.
- Well, we can all pretend
we care about pennies
but pennies are worthless Colin.
- It's all going down
the same place anyways.
- Do you take a shit in
the shower? It's pipes.
Like, that's literally your argument.
- No, shit won't go down in the drain.
- It will eventually with
water if you sprayed it enough.
- No.
- [Man on right] It's
literally the same train of thought.
- You don't go to a public park
and pee on the water fountain.
It's all pipes Colin.
- The problem with that is that you are
exposing your penis in public.
- What if I put a little
like bowl over my penis.
- Shit is not a comparable thing.
The comparable thing
that you could've said,
which he didn't, would be
like would you put semen
in the shower. And my answer is yes!
- For women, it's better
to pee in the shower
because you don't have to worry
about toilet paper getting your lady bits.
Because that's how UTIs get.
- But what about baby wipes?
Why not use the baby wipes?
- Okay! Rich guy.
- Rich guy!?
- I believe urine is
sterile and it's something
that you can literally drink.
- Have you drinken your own pee.
- I have never been stranded
on a deserted island
but if I did, I would.
- Yeah, I would too. But I wouldn't...
It's not like, in everyday
life every morning
I'm gonna take a swig of my own piss.
You weirdo. What are you doing!?
- Are you one of those people
that doesn't pee in pools either?
- No, I love peeing in pools.
- What's the difference!?
- The diff-- woah.
(dramatic music)
- I don't have exclusive
rights to my shower.
I share my shower with my girlfriend.
I don't want to do that to her.
- What are you doing to her?
- I'm forcing her to try to get clean
in a misty aroma of my urine.
- I wish I had a mop in there to mop up
the disgusting mess that is my own urine.
- It sounds like something
is up with your pee
if it's that gnarly.
- I'm not like, pissing all over myself.
Or like peeing all over the bathtub.
I'm peeing into a drain.
- This isn't an argument
about your marksmanship.
Which I'm sure is, no doubt great.
- Have you been in a
relationship with peeing
with the door open in front of someone.
- Yes, I've shit in front of
someone with the door open.
- We all have, but my point is, is that
you won't do it in the shower?
You're too good for that?
- 'Cause it's going on their feet.
- Do you like spray pee?
- I'm not saying my
dick is a shotgun blast
but I'm saying that when I'm peeing
into a stream of water hitting it
there's ricochet scenarios.
- Other people use washing machines that
have been filled with your clothes
full of your poop-stained underwear.
So are you then--
- How much pooping are you
doing in your underwear Colin?
- Bullshit. Everybody's underwear
has had a poop stain in it at some point.
You can't see it. Sometimes
there's just fecal matter.
Fecal matter on everything.
- Do you not clean your shower?
- [Man] How often do you
- [Man] clean your shower?
- Once a week perhaps.
- The lies!
- There's rules made to
pee in a certain place.
- So, if you're in a shower and you go
fuck, I have to pee at the
very beginning of the shower.
- I wrap it up. Like an
adult, dry myself off
- You put a condom on?
- [Man on right] What the fuck are--
- You wrap it up?
- Yeah, I'm gonna put a condom on my dick
and pee in it and make
a giant water ballon.
- Like I wouldn't be surprised
if you made that argument.
- Do you shower before sex?
- No! Of course not.
- I don't get that then.
- Why is that.
- 'Cause you said you don't want
to get your girlfriend dirty.
- Would you ever stick your
foot inside the toilet?
- Maybe if I dropped a necklace
down there or something.
- How's your necklace get in there?
Woops! No problem! Going
down there. Your hand's
all dripping piss when
you got your necklace out.
And you don't even wipe it off do you?
- Let's also keep in mind that people
who pee in the shower aren't always dudes.
- I mean I've watched girls pee before and
- (scoffs)
- [Colin] (laughs)
- Come on. Why.
- It's definitely more of
like a firehose situation.
- Right, it's like pshhhh!
- I'm simply letting it fall
down my thighs into the drain.
- I came into the shower
with pretty clean feet!
I'm gonna piss on them now in the shower.
- We'll you're a dirty human.
- I'm a dirty human!?
You pee on your feet!
- I use soap!
(dramatic music)
- Freedom, relaxation, time management...
- I think, that as a human,
you shouldn't do that.
- Lazy lazy lazy. You should
be ashamed of yourself.
- I am with the 99% here.
- 99% of people don't piss in the shower!
- I'm comfortable with
this shit filled air
that we breathe everyday.
- You live your life
Colin. I'll live mine.
(dramatic music)
- What do you think about catheters?
- Hooof! Like recreationally?
- Yeah, sure.
(laughs)